[Music]
okay everyone so this is my review of
nine perfect strangers episode four
brave new world like every episode this
season is directed by jonathan levine
but it's written by show runner david e
kelly and also show runner john henry
butterworth so for me which i'm going to
delve into with this review really
standout performances in this episode
from regina hall and bobby kanavali i
mean some really good scenes from the
both of them which are going to get into
but starting off this episode we get
more of this flashback that masha is
thinking of when she's confronted about
drugging them and this is when she was
shot in this parking garage and this
mysterious moment we don't know much
about but what annoys me is some of the
camera work in the show and here in
particular it was such an out of focus
shot to the point that it's so blurry
that we can't even see half the top of
her head nicole kidman so i thought it
was just overdone it was too much but
again it's something odd about the
flashback scenes in the show that aren't
really working but i do like we jump
into right where we left off the
cliffhanger from last week and we
learned that she's micro dosing them
with basically psychedelic mushrooms
which the drug name is psilocybin and
what's interesting is that she hasn't
been drugging jessica and ben so i like
that adds a little intrigue to why that
is but i love that it sets up in this
episode jessica wanting to know why that
is and now wanting to get in on the fun
and what really works is a lot of
payoffs in this episode just like that
one with things that are set up in this
opening scene at the dinner table but
also that it sets up everyone's angry at
her about the micro dosing and then by
the end of it everyone's on board it
does a nice job of brilliantly
converting our characters into seeing
the way of masha and you'll see masha is
basically confronting everyone like when
they're confronting her like hey we all
have our secrets here and this is where
she even loses someone being a killer
because she knows possibly that tony is
and this sets up tony revealing this
later on in the episode but i like that
matcha is like the role of wadsworth's
from the clue movie it's a great movie i
haven't seen it but it's a kind of
interaction that watchers will have with
the characters of clue that they're all
these messed up people and whenever they
confront him he knows how to manipulate
turn it back on them and we really get
to see masha's side of manipulation
throughout this whole episode big time
and you start to like her less and less
as this goes on even though we see this
stuff's kind of working and helping some
of the people you start to see her
motivations throughout this episode they
don't make her so innocent and what i'm
talking about with her brilliantly
manipulating people and turning things
back on the other person whenever they
accuse her or something when lars even
mentions she's gonna make gobs of money
off of this and this cure that she has
that everyone's gonna be cured of ptsd
mental illness anxiety sleep better
screw better like she says that kind of
lures everyone in but lars saying that
is a point he makes it's a good point
but then she counteracts with yes but
you know what i want you to write about
it i'm probably gonna make money but you
are going to get an award out of it so
why not do it for yourself so she knows
how to turn it to help and look like
it's going to really be a positive for
the other person what i do like also
about this episode is now the audience
is on it and that we know everyone's
getting drugged they shoot it a little
more trippy and what i mean by that
you're gonna see a lot more dutch angles
this episode and it seems like the way
our actors are behaving they're slowly
acting more on drugs which i thought was
really well done by the whole cast and
where you're seeing that vibe it starts
right away just to see what napoleon
heather and i've mentioned it's been my
favorite storyline of the show this
family and i still think that and
michael shannon's been brilliant and i
love though that heather's petting the
sheets and what you're seeing though is
important about this scene is that you
are seeing now because of this micro
dosing they're bonding better than ever
before and heather will mention this
later on the episode but they're having
passionate lovemaking this is something
that's complete 360 from when they first
got to this resort also with intrigue
built in this episode right we see that
yao is also having passionate love here
but with masha and he brings up his
concerns she even told him about the
micro dosing and he's worried about the
police but she's able to again spin
everything and she's like it's
constructive consent i told them and
they chose to stay so she knows how to
play the law here but also there is this
intriguing line she's like i didn't tell
them everything so relaxed i was like
what else is there planned here what's
really going on so that as an audience
member you get a little more excited
they give you little bread crumbs but
they don't give you the full picture
which i like i was worried we were gonna
get the full picture too early now what
threw me off a little bit i don't know
if i forgot about a scene in the
previous first episodes maybe i did
forgive me if i did but i feel like it
was abrupt that yao comes to see delilah
i didn't realize they were living
together on this campus and they shared
a bed because she's like you stay on the
couch tonight so maybe we could have
used a more intimate scene with them
together with no one else around to kind
of set this up more and how it's more of
a big thing that yao is sleeping with
masha and how hurt this would make
delilah but having said that it's
interesting that yao even accuses
delilah of being possibly the one
threatening masha and they do a good job
like i said in previous episodes we
already see delilah is the voice of
reason here she's kind of like the
normal person with the voice of the
audience here observing what we're
observing and she's calling out masha on
everything so clearly masha is this
villainous character that the show is
also brilliantly trying to fool you on
and you like her at points but it points
you see her real true nature and that's
exposed by delilah so the real voice you
can really only trust here is delilah
now a great scene with samara weaving
here is jessica she's playing a great
comic relief in this episode and i
thought this really worked well again
where they're making the drug smoothies
now she's like hey hi are there drugs in
here because i want them i thought this
was hysterical but you're also seeing in
the scene that napoleon was saying he
was you know a high school gym teacher
anti-drug but he's on board for this so
you're seeing like i said slowly through
this episode everyone's nose now they're
getting drugged but they're still there
i also like that this episode got me
more into this francis and tony
relationship she says this line when you
arrived you're a complete jackass and
now less complete jackass give this
thing a shot open up a new door which he
will to her by the end so again these
were good scenes they're purposeful
scenes that set up payoffs later in the
episode and it also makes tony and
francis in a sense their relationship
more likable characters you know and a
lot of things people say with writing is
that oh the most important thing is
character but really the most important
thing is relationships and if you get
good relationships in the show that just
enhances the character against the plot
then you feel emotional and i think
that's why this scene with francis and
tony leonard really work which we'll get
into but what's criminally disappointing
about this show and it continues
episodes there's no flow or rhythm
between the scenes the editing is wonky
and they don't cut together and serve a
constructive purpose really it's kind of
they just end abruptly there's so many
scenes like this even with tony and
francis here and just abruptly going to
carmel you feel like they didn't think
enough outside the box and how they were
planning it how to transition smoothly
from scene to scene it could use a
couple match cuts even just to connect
them something visually even to connect
the scenes it just seems like they've
shot a bunch of scenes and then kind of
just placed them together later on with
no thought to how we'd get from one
naturally to the other that kind of
takes away from the aspect of a pleasing
episode that it all comes together
smoothly it just doesn't but again what
i really liked here these 101 scenes and
now this is where regina hall is really
going to stand out and it's amazing
watching her knowing like she's mostly
known for comedy she was huge in the
scary movie film so to see her kind of
do amazing in this serious role is
awesome she's actually doing like a plus
plus work here and her 101 scene they
set up well her big scene later on
because masha's bringing up like i hear
you want to punch jessica in the face
you get violent and she's like oh
although i get violent i'm not violent
big difference but we will see that is
not the case later on and you see how
well masha reads people and has a plan
for how she's going to handle them but
this is stuff to really make us
sympathize with carmel here her husband
left her for a younger prettier thing
she says and the kids love her and she
even says she's a nice woman but she
wants to like you know punch her but
what's really sad is we learned he's had
other affairs even before that and he
said horrible things to her which masha
has a write down which you'll see in the
scene later on now the relationship i'm
not really sold on that's that
interesting yet is the one they're kind
of putting here with zoe and lars i
don't think it's really going anywhere
yet that we care too much about but i do
think what's interesting about this and
talking about people coming around as
she mentions to lars you know she's
excited he's gonna take this place down
with his journalism but he's hesitant
like we'll see like maybe he's not
expecting it to be this corrupt place he
thought like he even seems like he's
getting converted which is interesting
so i like the details to this scene with
the fencing and this is this exercise
where they take it out on this figure
here and you got to pay attention these
little things like masha calls out
francis and carmel to do this exercise
it is masha doing this she didn't ask
anyone to volunteer and she does that
because she knows these are the two
people that their problems are directly
angered towards somebody else that's
causing it where with francis is this
man who made up all these lies to her
and of course with carmelitis just awful
husband that said horrible things to her
and cheated and i like the little
details too where masha now calls out
francis for her defense mechanism of
just cracking jokes all the time she's
like no jokes here face your pain and it
gets her into that zone and she knew
with carmel just reading that book with
those bad things that was gonna set
carmel off but this is again where this
is where it's a questionable practice
and it turns some people off like tony
but again napoleon's even scared by it
but you see that's where heather's like
no you know was scared by it but there's
still so much good here and that we're
connecting like we never had then he's
like well what about zoey's 21st
birthday there anything about the sun
what committed suicide but zoe's in too
so even in those moments of doubt
they're now leaning more towards the
side of staying and buying in and that's
that effective cult-like nature with a
cold leg leader in masha and everyone
this is how people get brainwashed so
where i really think this is our first
emmy-worthy scene is with bobby kind of
ollie here as tony when he is bugging
out he's withdrawing from the painkiller
still he's getting micro dosed and he's
thinking about this man he accidentally
killed in a bar fight but him opening to
francis was so effective because you
know propsimus mccarthy is the scene
partner here and the way she cries
listening to him letting him do his
thing also but holy hell i mean this was
some of the best acting i've seen like
ever i was blown away and it comes to
just how he's handling things like
withdrawing he's slowly showing shame in
his face not looking her directly eye
and then eventually he's fully opening
up looking her direct in the eye when
he's saying lines like i don't know why
i'm here i'm a drug addict i got two
kids that don't talk to me i got a
career that ended up blink why am i here
i thought this was delivered so well
he's like i got nowhere else to go and
you really feel for tony and even
francis here so this was such a great
effective scene that was earned and like
i said it's that thing in writing like
relationships really at the end of the
day are the heart and core of successful
shows and film and right now this
relationship's really getting better as
the season goes on the big scene at
night right is mash is sitting at the
table with yao and delilah comes and
confronts her because she finds out
through just seeing it that they're
increasing everyone's dosage and it's
making the next protocol go too quick
and they purposely cinematography wise
go the dutch angle on masha during the
scene so this is really again the
camera's showing you you can't trust
this woman she is the villain here and
it's interesting that i thought it was
brilliant how they wrote in that delilah
here is the one who is also being
drugged she's knowingly being drugged
but you see how manipulative masha is
when she spins it when she says you know
yao told me you're not drinking your
smoothies and also yeah what a rat by
telling you know masha that about
delilah but she's like i put my guest
under your care and it's part of the job
to you know take your drugs and keep
your bipolarity under control so this is
really harsh words by masha she's
talking down to her like she's a robot
basically and it's brilliantly portrayed
by nicole kidman this is nicole kidman's
best scene to me yet and she's just so
good at deflecting these aggressive
moves by delilah and she's masha's just
not taking any of it seriously and she
just goes with take your medicine and
have some fun and it's such a thing that
cult leaders will eventually do where
they get power hungry they start making
irrational decisions like upping the
dosage like this and manipulating
everybody around them and it's hypocrisy
on the character of masha because we saw
it looked like she was helping someone
truly caring for someone in carmel and
that she was cheated on used by someone
but she completely is a hypocrite here
in the way she treats delilah where
delilah is cruelly hurt by that her
relationship with yao and that that's
not a loyal relationship and she's
telling her to ease up on yao so it's a
completely different viewpoint here and
she should be more understanding of
delilah's pain and where this really
worked well for me was this last scene
because everyone here you know you see
jessica's clearly on the mdma now that
yao gave her and that's gonna work for
relationships and helping that they said
and she's happy everyone around this
fire is happy they're even saying oh
what's in my smoothie they're excited
about what drugs could possibly in it so
they've come full circle 360 from the
beginnings episode where they're all at
a table and they were all resistant to
this and mad and now they're all in and
i love just like that crazy moment where
napoleon's saying something he stops
mid-sentence so we're seeing these drugs
this up dosage now having a serious
effect and it kind of scares you oh god
what's gonna happen next and if i'm
predicting anything you know napoleon's
the highest odds to die i think first
because if anyone dies it's gonna be him
because he's kind of already had a
closure with his story having that big
monologue he's getting all his wife
finally so it's gonna be interesting but
i do want to know what he's envisioning
we saw it again where he sees these two
kids whether it's his child's self or
something he knows about his son before
he committed suicide or a reason that
could have caused it that he never told
anyone so that's gonna be interesting
and we get this cliffhanger now that i
like where masha basically goes back to
her office she sees that pottery that
she showed francis which is interesting
it's shattered i don't think it's
francis threatening her though and we
see on the wall this crazy setup where
it says it's good to die so someone is
there watching her we know this because
they were watching her cliff jumping and
it's just something's coming after we
have to see who this person is and why
so it's intriguing i thought this was
the best episode of the season yet i'm
gonna give it a nine i'm happy because i
was really disappointed in episode two
and three and this gave me hope again so
it got me more in the edge of my seat
i'm more into the characters now and
it's standout episode for regina hall
and bobby carnivale here and it really
made me into this relationship between
tony and france which was important and
i didn't say this at the beginning of
the review but i just want to reiterate
do not put book spoilers anywhere down
below we're not talking about the book
here leave that for somewhere else i
haven't read the book myself so please
don't ruin it for me or anyone that will
be later on we'll have a separate video
for that but no book talk here please
we're just going to put our theories for
what we're seeing in the show no book
readers saying any spoilers please
please please you want to have this fun
and theorize and not have anyone's time
ruined but yeah let me know what you
thought down below for me this is a nine
again because it just had good payoff
amazing acting tighter writing here and
the only thing that's just holding it
back to me right now is this editing and
nothing is flowing great between scenes
it just feels patched together so
hopefully that gets tightened up as we
go on but who knows but yeah if you like
what i do here please subscribe and if
you really love what i do here i love
you can just sign up to be a member and
donate you get exclusive live streams
you get badges and it will help me do
this full time one day so i can make
more videos for you guys review more
shows and movies which is my dream and
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter for more of me and i'll see you
next time